when when you're growing up right
as a kid so some there's individual
sports
like what'd you play did you play sports
in high school
or whenever not really but you played
would you play soccer and basketball
yeah so there's team sports and
individual sports obviously the
individual sports is like wrestling
and they say it's a teeny or wrestling
team and stuff it's
true you're not alone as far as
performance goes you're performing by
yourself
you rely on your team for training
that's essentially it
you know maybe some support or whatever
um wrestling track and field
um unless you're in a four way one four
by four kind of situation but generally
speaking and that's country yes country
yeah so individual
sports versus team sports and football i
think is one of the better examples of a
team sport
because every single time you're relying
on everyone else to do their job
for you to be successful you know kind
of like a seal team you know you get the
machine gunner the you know
point man radio guy so versus tactical
echo just showed up
yeah so you know and then versus dave
burke
in the you know by himself yeah by
himself
like let's face it like if the other guy
fails it kind of makes you look good you
know in a way kind of thing as far as
like you know what you go through
football practice you're you they give
you the ball if you're running back
whatever
and one of your linemen fails he's going
to make you look bad
because he failed you know it's like
that that's how reliant like you got to
rely on your team that much
so if you grow up playing football
like you cut it kind of gets ingrained
in you like the team dynamic like the
importance of that
you know where you're doing your job
sure you want individual success yeah
you want to make touchdowns
you want to perform good for you know
whatever but you can't do that
if you're like separating yourself and
this is like daily
training and in games so it kind of
it kind of gets ingrained in you which
is kind of like i think
your position where from the beginning
there was no situation where
like you secretly hope that guy fails
you're like bro what can i do to help
you
you know because man if they fail right
you're getting
you're getting tackled it's different
from the great santini over here
i'm really glad i'm telling you all this
stuff about yeah but but that's not
to say that individual sports don't have
value because in a way they have more
value in this way
where performance wise if you fail in
like a performance meaning like in a
track meet or in a wrestling meet
if you fail oh it's all it's all on you
like sure you got to train good with
your your team for sure you got to do
all that stuff and you got to rely on
them for training and stuff like that
but no when it comes to game time bro
you go out on the mat or freaking lineup
and you know
well on the track check this out dave
burke
if you're in an aircraft by yourself
and you get shot down because you made a
mistake
you're the one that pays the price like
there's a there's a level of consequence
there
where you think to yourself well
look i appreciate that i got the rest of
team members here
i'm gonna be alone up in that aircraft
and i better be freaking good and if i
don't if i'm not good there's no one's
got
my back it's me